president is the best Communicator that
we have in the White House the best way
to get something done if you if you hold
near and dear to you that you like to be
able to anyway
I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report
what day is it where am I whose chair am
I sitting in who put my clothes on how
did I get my hair done it's February
21st 2023 we're live streaming on Rumble
YouTube and locals share subscribe if
you have not and if you want to play
along during the show join us at
reubenreport.locals.com uh today we're
going to be talking about that elderly
man pretending to be President Joe Biden
because on President's day yesterday as
you know this is President's week but
yesterday was President's Day instead of
staying here in the United States of
America and focusing on the issues that
average Americans have say inflation
other economic issues the Border perhaps
going to East Palestine where there is
an ecological disaster perhaps
unprecedented in American history he
went to Ukraine to give zelenski some
more cash that's what he did so we're
going to be talking about that and we're
going to really be focusing on
priorities what are the priorities of
this Administration what are the
priorities of the people who work for
this Administration and the media that
runs cover for them versus perhaps what
are your priorities as an American like
what do you actually think is important
and what do you want from the people
that are supposed to govern us I thought
we could start today with a little bit
of a throwback video uh this is Elon
Musk you might have heard about this
Elon Musk guys little-known Tech Guy
created something called PayPal many
years ago eventually started Tesla and
SpaceX and the boring company and then
he bought Twitter he's become a bit of a
free speech uh Aficionado I think you
could say online and uh no elon's
obviously doing a ton of great work and
I saw this throwback clip of him I
thought this would be a nice way to
frame the show this is Elon back in 2012
11 years ago talking to Jon Stewart on
The Daily Show about what we should be
pres doing to preserve Humanity which
generally is thought of as a pretty
important thing when I was in college
there were there were three areas that I
thought would most affect the future of
humanity and those were the internet
sustainable energy and space exploration
particularly making life multi-planetary
Elon I'm going to tell you something I'm
going to tell you something right now we
all thought that
but none of us could do anything about
it we just got high and played Dungeons
and Dragons
two
it so you would identify these three
areas how did you prioritize them how
did you create a hierarchy where you
were what you would move to next well
although I mean I thought about these
things kind of in the abstract in
college I didn't expect that I would
actually be doing them but it sort of it
just turned out that way right um
but the Advent of the internet and
particularly the sale of PayPal
um and gave me the capital to to start a
rocket company in a car company because
these are high Capital Endeavors right
um but I actually almost ran out of
money so it was a close call and both
both SpaceX and Tesla almost died yeah I
find a lot of startup rocket companies
really
right all right so I thought that was an
interesting way to start the show
because when Elon 11 years ago is laying
out the three things he is actually
really accomplished an awful lot of
those things or is in the process of
accomplishing those things and I would
say that's in stark contrast to our
government officials who say a whole
bunch of stuff and never do anything the
three things that he lays out there well
he talks about internet number one he's
done a little something for freedom on
the internet first with PayPal uh and
then certainly what he's doing with
Twitter right now then he talks about
sustainable energy well Tesla electric
cars this is generally thought of as a
good thing so he's two for two and life
on other planets well this is exactly
why he started SpaceX he actually shot a
Tesla into space just to orbit around
the world just the globe just because he
could I mean the guy's doing some real
stuff there uh and he's put himself in
the midst of this fight this crazy Free
Speech fight now it's interesting
because if you hear what he's saying
there at that time now remember Jon
Stewart Lefty liberal more young people
got their news from Jon Stewart than
anybody that's what they always used to
say about The Daily Show
Elon has accomplished a lot of those
things and is still in the fight Jon
Stewart bizarrely went the other
direction you know he retired I guess
from The Daily Show a couple years ago
and he was what I would he was a lefty
but like a somewhat sane liberal I think
a little more in line of the way maybe I
would have thought of myself a few years
ago or a little bit maybe more uh in the
Bill Maher sense of it but but Stewart
has subsequently gone completely crazy
he's gone all in on the woke stuff uh
and the trans stuff and the gender stuff
all in on all of that he also went
largely irrelevant like I think did his
show on HBO get canceled or not I mean
the guy's making he had a show on HBO
not or Apple TV Max whatever the hell
that thing is nobody's watching it they
paid him I'm sure 10 million bucks a
year to do it it's not relevant at all
okay that's fine side note
um I've mentioned this a couple times on
the show over the years I was an intern
at The Daily Show in 1999 right after
Craig Kilbourne left and John had taken
over actually had a few nice
interactions with John early on but he's
gone completely woke okay and what's the
other thing that progressives are all
going for right now they're really into
war have you noticed this because the
right right now and the conservatives
are basically saying hey how about we
stop giving this guy all the money you
know he's got nukes there could be a
problem here all the anti-war voices are
really on the right right now there's a
sliver of it on the left there really is
but most of it's on the right so you're
seeing the worksters are all going
pro-war uh here's Jon Stewart in March
of 2022 uh you know and he's he's into
zelinski and defending the place and
whatever we got to do this I got to ask
you before you go about another comedian
zielinski yes I mean it's it's just an
extraordinary extraordinary
extraordinary I mean for for look I'm a
comedian I know comedians we
I don't know that we would be able to
rise to the challenge of being in a
movie about war like and you see this
gentleman's courage and tenacity and the
way that he's leading his country it's
it it's it's incredibly moving and I
just uh my fear for Ukraine is that
we're going to get sucked into this idea
of a heroic narrative yeah while these
folks get surrounded in a long-term
Siege that's just going to cause so much
more death and destruction so the reason
I wanted to show you that is it's pretty
interesting it's like all right that was
about a year ago that was 11 months ago
March of 22. John you should be
screaming right now that over the last
11 months uh the Democrats have been
marching us towards War we are getting
closer to war it is fairly obvious and
when we find out who actually blew up
the Nordstrom pipeline Hint it was
probably us uh and as we keep giving
tanks and planes and Munitions and
things to Ukraine we are just funding
their War so in essence we are at War
and yet despite how horrible apparently
we are told it is it's so evil and
horrible and all those things and again
I know people locals had an office in
Ukraine we had to get guys out of
Ukraine we got them into another country
some of them we got here to the U.S so
I'm not diminishing that anything's
going on there but we are told it is so
horrific it is so awful but Joe Biden
managed to show up yesterday and wander
around Ukraine here you go very
significant Moment On The World stage
President Biden met with Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski during this
unannounced trip it comes just days
before the one-year Mark of Russia's
brutal invasion of Ukraine this moment
is highly significant this morning Biden
sending a strong message of support to
ukrainians as air raid sirens wailed
across Kiev underscoring the very real
risk involved in this trip
[Music]
both leaders spoke a moment ago about
the weight of this historic moment
guys it's so dangerous that the elderly
man pretending to be president walks out
there like a robot I'm totally convinced
they're actually replacing his body
parts with electronic robotic Parts
slowly and I think they did it to his
legs there if you see the way he walks
but it's so dangerous that that there
are Air Raid Sirens that means bombs are
being floated but they could just kind
of wander out there because yeah that
that feels real that doesn't feel staged
my nuts uh anyway all right Biden's
there I would imagine then that Biden
might be saying hey we got to wrap this
thing up let's look for a way out right
because that would be the same thing to
do I mean we got our own problems in the
U.S so hey zielinski can we tie this
thing together or
remind us that freedom is priceless
it's worth fighting for
as long as it takes
and that's how long we're going to be
with you Mr President for as long as it
takes
we'll do it thank you
oh we're going to be there for as long
as it takes I don't know maybe 20 years
you know we just got out of this
freaking Afghanistan thing we were there
for 20 years nobody knows why
billions and trillions of dollars all
the millions of deaths Iraq war a lot of
dead people Carnage you know collapsing
infrastructure everywhere none of it
really working let's just get in
get it in we'll just hang out for a
couple years I don't know a couple
decades just keep funding the thing you
know come on we're Americans
here's Kamala Harris by the way have you
noticed on the show lately I've started
the people were saying Dave you call her
Kamala and her name is Kamala and I've
I've started integrating that into the
show
anyway here's the vice president that
nobody likes uh and she's getting ready
to ratchet up the rhetoric against
Russia as well
the United States has formally
determined
that Russia has committed
crimes against humanity
I love how she tries to sound serious
with that like cracking voice thing at
least she didn't cackle on that one I
mean guys just trust me they are
ratcheting up getting us ready for World
War III this is what they want somehow
this has something to do with the money
laundering and the hunter Biden thing
and just like this is the new thing War
makes people rich and we got out of
Afghanistan and it was almost like
overnight this War began and we're just
funding it to the Tilt and now he's
doing War he's doing crimes against
humanity guys so he's doing crimes
against humanity those are those are
particularly bad crimes we better do
something about it now you would think
that uh zielinski might be when Biden
comes or you know crimes against
humanity these are bad things you might
think that zielinski would be like all
right can we get a uh a way out of this
thing is there any way out of this thing
thank you Joe for giving me this
unlimited check and you'll hang out as
long as we want
um but maybe I should make some
concessions too maybe there's something
I could give so that we could wrap this
thing up stop the Carnage stop the death
uh no there's no alternative to Ukraine
and in the EU there is no alternative to
Ukraine in NATO
there is no
no alternative to our Unity
hence there is no and should not be any
alternative to completely get rid of
Russian aggression
wouldn't it be the case that if your
country was being destroyed and your
people were being killed and all of
those things and I am not denying that
that is happening at some level that you
might be willing to negotiate but he is
not only saying go that we the status
quo is not good enough meaning if we
could just go back to the day before
aggression would that be good enough now
he's saying no it's beyond that you also
have to let us into NATO and Russia will
never allow Ukraine to be part of NATO
they don't want NATO at their borders
that's what this whole freaking thing is
about so he's saying to Putin hey the
one thing that you really want is the
one thing we will never give you thank
God I've got old Joe here writing me a
check forever saying we're going to hang
out forever and the Americans are going
to keep giving us money and weapons and
everything else it's it's really just
incredible and it's incredible to the
backdrop of I don't know at this point
with the leadership that we have in this
country and the complete dereliction of
Duty that they've done here with our
borders and our economy and everything
they put us through with coven what
moral right do we have at this point to
be telling anyone what to do I don't
know I think we all have to think that I
think there is a place for the United
States as the world's last superpower to
have a moral right I believe in American
exceptionalism I completely do this is
this country was founded so that
everyone could come here and make a
better life for themselves and then we
created The Beacon of Freedom that the
world has never seen before and may
never seen it again may never see again
we may regret it if we give it up but
right now we are in bed with some shady
people we are funding crazy Wars and
it's all of the left the left that was
the anti-war people War Republicans like
War George W bush likes War Republicans
are mean Burr
and everything has completely flipped on
itself uh here is uh Joe Scarborough
from the televised mental institution
known as MSNBC and he's very upset that
Republicans don't want to bankroll war
forever White House we're told is
preparing some massive Aid packages to
Ukraine to keep the government running
and Kiev on the one hand and then of
course much more military aid which
Richard Engel just showed us is
desperately needed and not just from the
United States but Europe as well jumping
in to get the ammunition at least for
starters into the hands of Ukrainian
Fighters right a lot to talk about there
at caddy but you've been talking uh the
sources on the hill that tell you even
if the Republicans were to do the
politically uh just idiotic thing and
cut off zielinski and the freedom
fighters in Ukraine uh Biden's Biden's
got got things lined up to keep them
going for quite some time yeah even if
you Republicans try to cut the cash
we'll figure out a way to keep it
flowing this is so bananas guys if this
was Trump just imagine if this was Trump
pushing for this war every every single
one of these people would be on the
reverse side of where they were at they
would be telling you that Putin is the
good guy and we are the aggressor so now
some Republicans are like um maybe we
should get some receipts remember Rand
Paul that was a big one uh well we gave
him 100 billion dollars could I just see
a receipt
how much are they tipping on this thing
like can I just see something no no
can't see that and more money will keep
coming and more arms will keep coming
and I guarantee you this there is no
military solution I don't know if like
you can see it guys but for some reason
I'm seeing it pretty clearly the guy has
nukes there is no situation where we
send in enough tanks and his army is
Dave we've killed every last Russian
we've removed vodka from every
supermarket in America we will take the
Russian hockey team off NHL on
Playstation we have really screwed the
Russians no one will ever see Drago in
Rocky IV again
and he's still got nukes but we seem to
want to just keep going and keep going
and keep going and the media is fueling
it they are absolutely fueling at people
like uh Joe Scarborough who are wrong
about absolutely everything and will
take any position on anything depending
on who is in power but let's shift
because
we seem to want to defend other people's
borders right we have this big Omnibus
package we're going to spend money to
protect Poland's borders I think we give
all these countries all of this money I
would be for cutting it cutting it 25
across the board on everybody I don't
know you guys got some problems you know
so do we sorry guys this year is going
to be a little thin the Christmas gifts
are going to be a little lighter this
year but we seem unable to do that I
understand so let's look at what's going
on right here in this country well Chris
Wallace Chris Wallace who was on Fox
remember and then he went to CNN plus
and that thing failed where is his new
show now do we even know it's on CNN
good for this guy he made it from CNN
plus to CNN poor guy anyway he had a
Secretary of Homeland Security Alejandro
mayorquez on to talk border policy
because everyone knows it ain't working
but here's mayorkis and his his very
fine eyebrows migrants believe there's
an open border Chris have you heard some
of our political leaders speak about the
Border and communicate that the border
is open I don't think the more than 1.5
million people who have been removed or
expelled from the border would consider
the Border open but political leaders
um communicate that the border is open
that is music to The Smuggler's ears and
the Smugglers themselves you're going to
blame us all on Republicans absolutely I
mean you're not going to say that the
administration and the policies on
remain in Mexico are title 42 or
stopping construction of the wall that
that had no impact Chris that's not what
I said I'm just I'm just citing for you
a few things and please allow me
number one uh they they use that
rhetoric number two we're dealing with
smuggling organizations that are far
more sophisticated than than they were
when I prosecuted them for 12 years as
an assistant United States Attorney and
as the United States Attorney I don't
really care what he said about the
Border can we just talk about his
eyebrows for a second because it's an
interesting thing to have no hair on
your head and all that hair on your
eyebrows I think we should call that the
mayorcus for now on if you see somebody
walking down the street and they're
completely bald but they've got these
just incredible eyebrows that's a
majorcus all right as for the content
look it's just silly like of course he
was trying to blame the Republicans for
everything and when the Republicans were
securing the border and building a wall
and doing all those things they said it
was racist we know that we've had more
border uh border breakages more border
passings illegally in the last year than
I think the last five years combined
like it is just absolutely endless but
as he said there but now that you know
they've got all this new technology it's
so much more complex well are these
Smuggler like are these border Smugglers
are they brighter than us
or are you guys all idiots I think it's
the latter uh anyway it continued uh
majorcus and uh the border is it secure
but when you say it's what does secure
mean to you it certainly doesn't mean
that people aren't able to get across
the border illegally of of course that
is that by that measure the board has
never been secure right
um since the Department of Homeland
Security was created
individuals have invaded so by what
measure is it secure now sir so there
there is not a common definition of that
if one looks at the statutory definition
the literal interpretation of the
statutory language if one person
successfully evades law enforcement at
the border uh then we have breached the
security of the Border oh you
yep I did a lot of them yesterday you
hack you are nothing but a hack yes we
understand that technically
if a million people try to get through a
border and we stop all but one then the
border is not secure because one did get
through but do you think that's really
what we're talking about here you
ridiculous buffoon of course that's not
what we're talking about what was the
number it's about one and a half million
this year was it about one and a half
million something like that about one
and a half million people have illegally
gotten through our border this year we
give them phones we say oh we'll call
you we'll call you in a couple weeks you
want a little cash too here's your Obama
Phone have at it oh you brought a little
fentanyl with you well just ended up to
San Francisco there's always a shortage
up there it's so ridiculous but this
these are the linguistic games that
these people do with absolutely
everything I can't Define what it's the
same people that can't Define what a
woman is I just put it together you ask
them what a woman is they don't know
what a woman is you ask them what a
secure border is they don't know what a
secure border is they cannot say
anything true whatsoever and also they
can never acknowledge that maybe they
had a little something to do with it
what what do you think is the basis for
their calling for your impeachment do
you think you've done anything wrong no
I don't I think it is a um a
disagreement over policy and I think it
is used for political purposes uh to
continue a negative dialogue about a
migration challenge that is not unique
to the United States to continue that
dialogue to uplift it for political
reasons
so negative everybody just because
they're flooding your town with fentanyl
and that they are illegals raping your
wives and your children don't be so
negative you're just a negative Nelly
let's have an uplifting conversation
about fentanyl laced rape
so it's nuts it's nuts it's absolutely
nuts
but it's time
to do something sane and you know what
that means it's Florida time
it's far at a time so what what's
happening well DeSantis isn't taking it
when illegals get here however they get
here by boat or they come in you know
through the ground through another state
we get rid of them that's what we do and
we should do it and if the federal
government won't do their job we'll do
it at the state level uh here's DeSantis
going after Biden on this ridiculous yes
mayorcus open border policy
unfortunately the Biden Administration
has done slim to no work to actually try
to prevent opioids from entering our
communities in the first place we know
that things like fentanyl are
manufactured in China and they are sent
to North America via uh into our country
via the southern border between the
United States and Mexico yeah that's it
like let's just say you don't care about
the Border like for some reason you just
don't care about it or you don't care
that little border towns are are being
overrun you live in let's say I don't
know Martha's Vineyard and generally
speaking you don't look at immigrants
they don't get illegal immigrants you
don't get these people right but when
you do you know that they're going to
get removed within like 12 hours so you
don't really care about that you might
care about fentanyl but you probably
don't either because if you live in
Martha's Vineyard you probably don't but
you know in a lot of America's blue
cities you might care about the fentanyl
problem right because it is deeply
connected to the homeless problem uh if
you're someone who's ever watched a
zombie movie you might care about that
because these cities are turning into
zombie apocalypse zones so DeSantis is
doing the right thing we will not take
that here we're not just going to have a
boat show up at the harbor in Fort
Lauderdale and a whole bunch of people
are going to get off and figure out
where they're gonna live and who they're
gonna sell fentanyl to and who their
whose houses they're going to break into
we don't have that which is why we have
something like a 20-year uh drop in
crime the lowest crime in about 20 years
Statewide here I mean it's nuts so what
else are we doing here in Florida well
we're also going to fight the
substantive substance abuse which we do
have which already is significantly less
than most other states use the
205.7 million dollars that Florida is
receiving from the opioid settlement
agreement to further our efforts to
prevent and treat substance abuse in the
State of Florida now we have a whole
host of other things that we're doing
now what's interesting about this is as
a general rule I don't love the idea of
government spending a ton uh when it
comes to drug related things I remember
when I lived in California there were
always Billboards everywhere like the
California Center for a drug whatever
it's free to go in and it's like man if
you think a government bureaucrat middle
management anything is going to have a
crack addict or fentanyl addict walk in
and if you think you're going to walk
out any better because of this guy like
probably not going to happen however
Florida now has a track record of doing
things right so we're going to take this
200 million we don't have a major
fentanyl problem here also because we're
not only are we doing policing rights so
we're actually arresting these people so
the dealers of these crazy drugs who
were literally I mean I literally saw it
in San Francisco people walking around
and exchanging driving it's hard to see
exactly what they're doing like are you
handing cash to somebody but just
they're literally injecting each other
on the street doing drugs you could see
people doing deals Shady things by the
wall snorting this or that and whatever
the hell they're doing which I always it
they smoke fentanyl I can't do it again
which way do they smoke Fentanyl and
snort crack or you snort cracking
look at these I got these upstanding
citizens in this room nobody knows
nobody knows do your own research on
that people call a cousin in San
Francisco and find out uh the point is I
do believe that the 200 million we're
going to spend uh will actually do
something the proof will be in the
pudding uh DeSantis continued yesterday
because I think this this Ukraine thing
that we started the show on is is
interesting because it's causing a real
shift in things right because there is
this general idea you know Democrats
want peace and Republicans want war and
it's actually flipping right in front of
our eyes
well they have effectively a blank check
policy with no clear strategic objective
identified and these things can can
escalate and I don't think it's in our
interest to be getting into proxy war
with China getting involved uh over
things like the Borderlands or over
Crimea so I think it would behoove them
to identify what is the Strategic
objective that they're trying to to
achieve but just saying it's an
open-ended blank check that is not
acceptable yeah you're right it's just
not acceptable what situation would you
do this if you were lending money to
somebody oh you could just lend borrow
money forever I will literally lend you
money forever any situation if you were
in a business arrangement with somebody
we're just going to fund you forever
doesn't matter if you're profitable or
if you actually sell anything or do
anything positive with the money so of
course this answers is right you need an
objective you need an attainable goal
but then we've also got zelenski saying
our attainable goal and we are not going
to stop short of this is getting into
NATO except we know that's never going
to happen and the other guys got nukes
it is a screwy screwy situation ladies
and gentlemen the show is a little
abbreviated today I know that we're
normally we've been doing shows that are
going about an hour now my intention
when we started these these daily shows
was to go about 40 minutes we've been
usually doing about an hour we're only
going about 27 28 minutes today because
I've got to get to the local studio for
uh for a big live in-person interview
which I think we're going to be posting
next week if I'm not mistaken uh next
week you'll you'll understand why it was
worthy of cutting this one a little bit
short but I appreciate your time so
there'll be no no post game show today
because we got a bolt right out of here
uh if you want to play along during the
show join us as always everyone
locals.com we leave you with the elderly
man pretending to be president thank you
and see you tomorrow Lynch for simply
being black nothing more
with white crowds white families
gathered to celebrate the spectacle
taking pictures of the bodies and
mailing them my postcards hard to
believe but that's what was done and
some people still want to do that
[Music]